et nous avons trouvé pierre conesa
ancien haut fonctionnaire spécialiste
des questions stratégiques
internationales on revient avec vous sur
cette crise des sous marins est la
mise en colère paris paris qui
s'opposent à ses alliés américains
australiens et britanniques explique
henno expliquez nous donc ce qui se joue
dans cette zone indo pacifique
aujourd'hui
c'est pas seulement dans la zone ados
pacifique
comme je vous le disais je travaillais à
l'intérieur du système administratif
d'exportation d'armements la
caractéristique de ce secteur d'activité
c'est que vos concurrents sont également
vos alliés donc toute rivalité si vous
voulez sur un marché d'armement est
toujours enfermé dans une dans des
limites si vous voulez qui fait qu'ils
font que l'on ne va pas jusqu'à la
rupture deuxième remarque les américains
nous ont déjà fait un coût de cette
nature en 1983 dassault aurait vendu des
mirage 2000 à l'arabie saoudite
le contrat la signature du contrat était
prévu alors que la veille si la
signature du contrat les et les
saoudiens ont changé ils ont acheté deux
des tornado britanniques mans donc si
vous voulez c'est un scénario qu'on a
déjà connu et c'est pour ça que je vous
dis qu en fait la crise est pas pire que
ce qu'elle a été à deux moments
simplement là en l'espace il ya une
dimension stratégique qui est très grave
c'est que alors que la france interdit
d'exporter des sous marins nucléaires
les américains décident de le faire
c'est à dire c'est une prolifération
nucléaire extrêmement inquiétant moi je
comprends l'inquiétude des chinois
d'ailleurs des autres partenaires vous
savez le sous marin nucléaire est une
arme de suprématie c'est une arme de
menace donc il faut quand même se rendre
compte que ce n'est pas le chic de
substitution d'un produit par un autre
produit c'est un précédent qui pourrait
finalement incité d'autres états à
vouloir se doter de ce type de
submersibles et c'est ça qui redoutait
aujourd'hui
il ya deux choses différentes d'abord la
volonté déjà ancienne des américains de
tuer l'industrie française de défense
quand je vous ai cité un exemple en 83
sur l'aéronautique l'a fait longtemps
que les mecs à essayer d'avoir la peau
de de la firme d'assaut parce que la
france est un des rares pays à pouvoir
produire des avions de combat de 5e
génération exactement rivaux des
américains et en plus c'est des produits
qui sont plus adaptés un certain nombre
de marchés parce que pour entretenir un
rafale il faut beaucoup moins de monde
que pour entretenir un f 15 f 35 donc
j'en ai sur des armes et si vous voulez
dans lesquelles le produit français plus
adapté ça c'est le première
caractéristique deuxième chose on va
passer au delà de la mousse si vous
voulez de la mécontentement exprimés et
ses draps mais vous avez l'exportation
d'un monstre métier de voyous c'est à
dire que il ya eu par exemple dans les
musiques mentation d'avoir énormément
d'affaires de corruption puisque ce sont
des marchés qui sont des secrets défense
et donc vous savez bien que dans les
pays du golfe c'est une des bonnes
manières d'obtenir des contrats c'est de
savoir qui les touchent et combien voilà
donc il faut garder tout ça à l'esprit
et ne pas faire de morale sur un sujet
comme celui là simplement voilà ça
prouve que l'on est dans une espèce de
rivalité aujourd'hui les america's
estime unipolaire c'est à eux de décider
de tout maintenant faut savoir quelle
est la conséquence stratégique et
comment dire qu'elle est quelles
conséquences intellectuelle on va tirer
de cette situation et alors justement il
avait dit je reprends vos termes nos
alliés sont aussi nos concurrents
qu'est-ce que cela dit donc cette crise
des sous marins des des relations que la
france doit s'entretenir avec ses alliés
notamment américains
vous savez moi c'est ce qui est amusant
c'est que je retrouvais enfouir des
papiers un article que j'avais écrit je
prends en 2005 quelque chose comme ça
que j'avais appelé les états unis sont
ils un risque l'europe et le monde
diplomatique il a publié avait changé en
maîtresse que les américains sont une
menace pour l'europe voyez combien il
est difficile de penser les états unis
quand vous êtes occidental entre la
nécessité de la couverture contre l'otan
et la nécessité comprendre que vous avez
aux états unis des néoconservateurs qui
eux se fiche complètement de ce qui se
passe en europe complètement et vous
avez effectivement aussi en france les
néo conservateurs qui estiment que le
seule manière pour la france du
survivent c'est de poursuivre tout ce
que font les américains rappelez vous la
rupture chirac le balcon sarkozy
hollande
chirac qui était le dernier bout lien
c'est rouler vos listes delà du système
française admire ses successeurs se sont
empressés de reprendre la bévue qui a
consisté à ne pas aller en irak or il
avait raison voyez donc on va se
retrouver à l'avenir dans des situations
où effectivement la france qui reste
avec la grande bretagne la seule armée
si vous voulez susceptibles de faire de
la projection de force devra prendre des
positions qui n'ont plus relax que tous
les opérateurs français ont proposé ces
dernières années et cette question cette
séquence ans de cette crise des
sous-marins qu'elle pose aussi
finalement la question de la
soutenabilité de la politique française
de défense et du coup d'une politique de
défense européenne pour peser davantage
face aux états unis mais ça prend la
défense européenne si vous voulez ça
fait des années qu'on essaye de trouver
un concept là le contradictions internes
à l'europe qui est évident c'est que
tous les anciens pays satellites ou non
que par regard fixe et que sur la russie
se disent donc que si jamais les
américains s'éloigne il risque de
retomber sous la coupe roche est ce donc
pour ça que vous retrouvez des polonais
des tchèques et des roumains en irak sur
le pays dans lesquels il avait rien à
faire et simplement par discipline ils
ont suivi les amériques à la moitié de
l'europe a suivi les américains en irak
quand même et seule la france
l'allemagne et la russie se sont
opposées à cette guerre donc vous voyez
qu'on est dans un système pensé un
concept de défense européenne n'est pas
du tout évident donc hélas c'est une
véritable difficulté parce que tant
qu'on faisait semblant on se réunissait
qu'on en parle et qu'on avance et douce
matt serra salée mais le break site
retirer si vous voulez l'armée
britannique et l'autre arme est
important de laurent est donc
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de moyens
véritablement de relancer la défense
européenne c'est sur ces mots qu'on
termine cet échange merci beaucoup
pierre conesa ancien haut fonctionnaire
spécialiste des questions stratégiques
internationales